live from the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion
in Los Angeles California the 71st
annual Academy Awards
brought to you by Revlon revolutionary
products for revolutionary women the
all-new Chevy Tracker it gets around
American Express weather you're seeing a
movie or making one we can help you do
more and popsie the joy of cola welcome
to a star-studded evening here at the
Music Center the stars are out tonight
to celebrate the best of the best it's
Sunday night at the Oscars and the fans
in the stands join those around the
world to cheer on their favorites last
year's Best Actress winner for as good
as it gets Helen Hunt Geoffrey Rush
Supporting Actor nominee and Oscar
winner for shine Jennifer Lopez double
Oscar winner and still photographer
Kevin Costner joining the Oscars once
again to perform Celine Dion Patrick
Stewart Star Trek star respected British
actor with Hollywood's number one
the army Archerd
Best Screenplay Oscar winners and
buddies Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
celebrating his first Oscar nomination
for affliction James Coburn
popular actor Val Kilmer
and here they are from
PricewaterhouseCoopers the keepers of
the Oscar ballot Lisa burrows Ian Greg
garrison two-time Oscar winner nominee
three nominations for life is beautiful
actress screenplay and director Roberto
Benigni Mariah Carey multi-million album
seller
tonight steep Tyler lead singer Baris no
Angelica Houston three-time Oscar
nominee she won for Krypton's honor
Sofia Loren international star and Oscar
win over two women comic actors Steve
Martin and Oscar winner Goldie Hawn
double Oscar winner Tom Hanks and wife
Rita Wilson world's famous oscar-winning
director Steven Spielberg and wife Kate
Capshaw beautiful star of The Mask of
Zorro Catherine zeta-jones now let's go
inside and enjoy the 71st annual Academy
Awards